ah bonjour antoine alors les deux hommes
ont abordé plusieurs sujets de
l'actualité internationale mais aussi
les relations bilatérales avec la
perspective prochaine d'un gros contrat
à gaz et
wim on a tout à fait le ministre
hongrois des affaires étrangères va se
déplacer lundi prochain à saint
pétersbourg pour négocier avec gazprom
d'un contrat de fourniture de gaz pour
les 15 prochaines années un contrat qui
devrait aboutir d'ici d'ici cet automne
budapest qui a également fait savoir que
la hongrie commencerait à produire le
vaccin russe spiegel et ce dès le début
2022 dès le début de l'année prochaine
les deux hommes ont ensuite évoqué les
grandes problématiques de l'actualité
internationale avec en particulier
l'afghanistan et à ce propos sergueï
lavrov a évoqué a réagi à la dernière
déclaration du chef de la diplomatie
européenne
écoutez
le numéro un de la diplomatie européenne
josep borrell a déclaré dès que les
américains se sont retirés de
l'afghanistan nous ne pouvons pas
laisser l'afghanistan entre les mains de
la russie et de la chine
si le chef de la politique étrangère
européenne réfléchit à l'aide de ce
genre de catégorie j'éprouve de la pitié
à l'égard des pays de l'ue eux qui sont
obligés d'écouter visiblement de
soutenir une telle philosophie à coup
sûr sauf que ce n'est pas de cela que
monsieur bord elle devrait se préoccuper
il faut réfléchir plutôt à la façon dont
les afghans pourraient améliorer la
situation dans leur pays dans les
meilleurs délais
il a également été question de l'ukraine
et le ministre hongrois a qualifié
d'inacceptables les violations de kiev
contre les minorités au sein de leur
paye en effet pas moins de 150 mille
ukrainien d'origine hongroise vivent sur
le territoire ukrainien à budapest
estime que les droits de cette minorité
sont l'objet d'atteintes en particulier
au niveau de l'éducation de
l'enseignement de la langue hongroise
sergueï lavrov s'est quant à lui exprimé
sur la récente initiative de kiev qui a
pour objectif de faire revenir la crimée
au sein de l'ukraine écoutez
bien sûr qu'il s'agit d'une action
russophobe est créée de manière
artificielle ou le peuvent ce constat et
ils feront tout leur possible pour
soutenir artificiellement ses sentiments
pour renforcer ces phénomènes néo nazis
en ukraine moderne
ces manifestations sont favorisées par
les autorités de kiev ainsi que par les
dirigeants des pays occidentaux
la hongrie est probablement l'un des
pays d'europe un des pays de l'union
européenne avec lequel la russie
entretient les meilleures relations et
cela s'est encore une fois vérifié
aujourd'hui autant au niveau du
développement des relations bilatérales
que de la convergence de leurs positions
de leurs points de vue concernant les
grands dossiers de l'actualité politique
internationale
merci entre les roues pour toutes ces
précisions de dates en direct de moscou